thank you all very much I want to
congratulate Matt and I give my
condolences to
Elizabeth on their anniversary 26 years
i learned i had not understood that
Elizabeth was married when she was four
years old and yeah pending I but for
penny Elizabeth would qualify for the
most patient woman in the room tonight
thank you for coming I'm in contrast in
my mind since I came to town this time
I'll explain it to you so tonight was
kind of cool wasn't it sort of odd and
magical and what produced that the
answer is love and I'll explain that in
a minute but so why did Vince help us
why is his whole team here helping us
make a radio station why is Hugh Hewitt
here what produced all of that and then
the people who came over here tonight so
you know I know Hugh Hewitt a long time
before he ever got into radio I knew Tom
cotton a long time before he got into
politics even before he got into the
military think of that right that those
people are here tonight and the way I
think of them is I love them because
they're excellent it's something that I
admire I think they're good before they
were influential I thought they were
good and I and I didn't really care as
much whether they would become
influential I thought they might I even
thought back then that I might but
mostly I thought no it's about these
things right if you think about it the
life of every student is dominated by
thoughts like that or else they can't
learn because you start learning old
things and they're not influential
anymore so that's one contrast but
what's the other one
what was it a month ago now national
news hit that Hillsdale College was
omitted from the great production of the
Obama administration the college
scorecard simply omitted not not there
and so an intrepid reporter from the
Hillsdale Daily News closely followed by
a reporter from the Hillsdale Collegium
called the Department of Education to
inquire about this and before I tell you
the answer that they gave I will tell
you the real answer which emerged in a
few days the real answer is the college
scorecard is an exercise in big data
because the government is interested to
know everything about your life and
because it starts with some proprietary
information that other people cannot
legally get like tax rolls in the
Internal Revenue Service and student
loans and repayment rates and amounts
and such as that and it's now also
buying lots of data in the way that
Google and other places have it to sell
and so what they want to do is they want
to draw a picture of how successful you
are in life and then rank colleges by
that and the reason we're left off that
is because we don't participate in the
federal student loans and the Pell
grants and stuff and so they don't have
the original data they could only get
that from us and we don't give it to
them
so the actual answer seems to be that
we're not part of the system what's the
answer they gave they're not really a
degree-granting institution and of
course they're saying this to people who
live in Hillsdale Michigan and I said to
the college paper you know how could the
college newspaper you know because you
have to remember my life is really weird
I I have a bunch of 20 year olds writing
stories about everything i do just about
every week you know two of them sit
right back there marica and Betsy who
you know and they're they're like you
know Betsy is a big journalist now for
The Daily Beast the liberal places hire
her and Marika what are you and that
Marika was editor of the college paper i
can what are you doing now Marika all
right you are you work for SAS huh
you've always been sassy gear and yeah
and see these are these are you know and
they used to write about me every
weekend I mean it's excruciating and and
so they asked me what do I think about
this how could the United States
Department of Education be so
drastically wrong because first of all I
think that there are twenty-seven
hundred colleges in the country and I
think by every assemble of numbers that
you can put together we're somewhere in
the 50 best right and I mean just in the
raw data stuff a CT scores graduation
rates all that stuff right forget I'm
going to get to that forget any other
qualitative information as if that might
matter about college education I mean
just the numbers how could they say that
we don't grant degrees and then argued
with two different people who live in
town how could they say well really they
only give
certificates that's ignorant and
arrogant and those are not qualities
that you want among the powerful right
why would they say that the college
paper asked me I said Hillsdale College
1844 United States Department of
Education 1979 never actually very good
at history were they but you see the
point a great vast thing lending
credibility acting with the force of law
and whatever else we are without knowing
anything else about us they have to know
that we are citizens of the United
States of America and deserve and
require their protection why would they
not give that we didn't do anything to
them except not take their money and I
guess we talked bad about them too but
but I don't think they know they're so
it's about that contrast that i'm going
to talk just for a minute see the reason
all of us care about the three people
who've walked in this room tonight we
were all thrilled to see them you know I
told you two of them of very
long-standing friends of mine one of
them almost as long and one of them that
long with Matt and I care about him for
that but they're powerful too and they
offer promise about that problem I just
stated because the government is
ignorant and arrogant and does not
protect the things that's supposed to
protect what is college all about after
all it's amazing how little they know
about that at the united states
department of education I you know I'm
62 and I've been you know I have a PhD
which means I went to college for until
we had children
and and what you know but for the
children I'd still be going you know I
was happy happier in my life you know my
wife says one dear you didn't really
leave college did you so I know
something about it right and then all
this time I have never heard the United
States Department of Education describe
accurately what education is do you know
what it is it comes from a Latin word it
means to lead fourth fourth don't you
see that's a value term it's like growth
how do you know when you a thing to stop
growing and it begins to decay
everything does everything that lives
does that how do you know when the
moment of growth is finished isn't at
the moment when it becomes fully itself
in other words when it's essentially
what it's made to be in other words when
its best or most good and isn't forth
just like that the Bible says train up a
child and the way you should go what do
you think that means what do you want
for your own children penny and I have
four right what do we want for them well
of course we want them to pay the bills
we want them to not go to jail we want
them to have a sufficient income we want
them to pay back their student loans if
they have any which in my case they
don't I work in a college you get free
tuition big perk so what what do you
want apart from that of course you want
that but what do I want to them to those
two girls back there right and to that
boy right over there and there are some
others there's gerke back there right
these people are students of mine what
do I want for them I want them to live
well
that's what you want for your children
sometimes it doesn't happen much at
hillsdale college although because I've
taken my children to visit other
colleges as prospective students I know
that the conversation at three other
colleges all which profess to be liberal
arts college in the admissions process
when you come to visit is dominated by
questions of security success and money
once in a room with more people than
this in it at a college in Southern
California where I got a fair amount of
my own education I listened to them ask
those questions for more than an hour
and my daughter happened to not be in
the room and the other places I went
they get one of my children with me and
they wouldn't let me speak but I was cut
loose right and after about an hour i
said i cauterized my hand and i got
recognized and i said what is the most
important thing that my daughter will
know and what will her character be like
when you have finished with her and
every head snapped around in the room
just like that you know and then I'm
known in that town and the admissions
officer by the way who was later
dismissed for fudging his reports of the
a.c.t scores to rise in the rankings
said welcome back to town dr. Arnn and
then the rest of the day people were
coming up to me and saying that was such
a good question and I said and you why
did you not ask that question and they
said you know we didn't think of it but
that is the question isn't it I can tell
you I the next week I went to such an
event at Hillsdale College afraid that I
would be horrified to discover that was
the tunnel it's not do you see the point
do you know the first document that
founded education government education
in america is the northwest ordinance
and you know what it says religion
morality and knowledge being
necessary to good government and the
happiness of mankind schools and the
means of Education shall ever be
encouraged and that is one of the
fundamental laws of the United States
that's not an ordinary statute that
banks in the United States Code
alongside the Constitution and the
Declaration and the Articles of
Confederation is one of the formative
laws in the history of the country so is
it any wonder if the government thinks
of education like that that it treats us
as commodities in so many other ways as
factors of production as people who can
contribute to some project of its isn't
that common now isn't it true that the
first reaction of somebody working in
the Department of Education who deals
with the press the first reaction is to
offer a slander against private and it's
a slander that's what it is if the
slander laws were different if they were
the way they are in England today we
could prosecute them for that slander
because that's what it is it is a legal
wrong why would they offer that to
protect themselves so I'll close with
this what should be done about that the
problem is so big Jenny Thomas my old
friend not that old she's we've been
friends for a long time but she was just
a girl when it started I said I asked
her a question about something that's
going on because you know she tracks
every evil thing that's happening in the
country and and she spends her and by
the by her emails i can tell you she
spends about 14 days 14 hours a day in a
state of alarm
and she said they're just so many
legions of them right it's overwhelming
and this thing that happened to us you
know we're strong they're not going to
hurt us until they kill us right but
will be very hard to kill it looks
hopeless it looks like an overwhelmingly
difficult situation but is it cuz what
made Tom cotton and Paul Ryan what they
are what made him like that if you work
in a college you would never say that I
would never say that I did that I did
not in fact I was interested in them
because I didn't have to because I
thought this is a person to befriend
because it's amazing what he can achieve
state senator Morrell back there Jenny
my boy Ryan sitting over there Marika
and Betsy and gerke boy oh there's
wigman second in his line right and
Butler what are they like Emily works
for me now Billy outstanding senior man
useless Nathan and Sophie it's amazing
him I'm done now I can't name all but
what do they like if you recognize the
principle of self-government in people
you can befriend them but if you treat
them like commodities they will hate
that and that means that the army at
their disposal they always know exactly
how big it is but the argue army against
them is infinite in size because it can
be recruited from everybody who wishes
to live a fully human life
and that means ultimately everybody so
now why doesn't that just happen and the
answer is statesmanship is very hard
especially in a time like this where
we've been seduced by promises of utopia
and we believe them in part because
we're so wealthy and so powerful now
although we're quaking some aren't we
then it's very hard to turn that around
but the forces of their latent to do it
and I was believed in being optimistic i
studied winston churchill what do you
learn from him what you learn is he'll
be hell and then we'll win or eventually
die trying which is a tolerable result
that's what you learn there is in fact
nothing to fear and then look what
walked in here tonight I'm telling you
there's some talent it's like the best
potentially we don't know yet about them
everybody's gloomy about the
presidential race it's the best one I've
seen since Reagan and we don't know if
they're good enough it's very hard it's
a very difficult art people always say
where's Weston Churchill today where's
Abraham Lincoln today and I respond
where are they anytime once in a while
they come along what can we do then the
answer is we can learn about them and by
that process make ourselves more like
them and discover in ourselves what it's
possible for us to be that's why it's
inspiring by the way to teach the young
because all those names I just called
out there's no limit on what they can do
and they're never going to rest I said
to jenni tonight I said don't you
understand that everybody you ever met
who did something great her husband
who's one of the greatest living
Americans you see why is he that cuz he
bears the pain of it because he gives
himself to it because there's not any
difficulty you won't go to Winston
Churchill had that he was a genius too
maybe we're not geniuses but we can all
have that and when we recognize it in
people we can support them and help them
and then the cause of right will not be
suffered to fail so now you see what
we're here to do we're all enrolled in
it we've taken each other's time we
belong to each other we must do the work
come what may so we sho thang
you